run anywhere if you're gonna hit him we
can fit them in a wall
to 17 over six is lit up he's taking off
nice to 503 we're invites go ahead
Ryan
[Music]
[Music]
way away
[Music]
13 15 30 to 19 radio
[Music]
that feeling like right here right in
front of me
take him out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
82 Southbound 82.
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you're here with it
you need to continue to pursue
we need to take it
[Music]
approaching 42 82 going west 73 miles an
hour heavy traffic all green lights so
far coming through here
[Music]
we go we are Northbound on 57 North 57
from south side and you're just going
away are we going on 20.
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Chestnut
[Music]
17-21's out
yeah
foreign
[Music]
out
[Music]
in China
get out of there show me your head
let's go
[Music]
all right
[Music]
Northbound on South westbound on Charles
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
now heading south on Wallace Street
[Music]
westbound on Michigan right now
westbound on Michigan
[Music]
foreign
Park
[Music]
I believe
[Music]
where is he
right here
you know
today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
so much
again
Union
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
crossbar
foreign
abortion
Al
um
[Laughter]
431 we have a two vehicle he T-boned
another car he's going to be trapped I
need to extrication
oh
foreign